notre séance s'est retransmis sur Public
Sénat et sur notre site internet ça
cassera attentif au respect des uns et
des autres et au respect du temps de
parole
la parole est à notre collègue Emmanuel
cappuie pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
voilà 21 mois mes chers collègues que la
France est en situation de sécheresse
météorologique voilà 23 jours qu'il n'a
pas plu dans les départements du Nord de
la France même cet hiver la sécheresse
était-elle que plusieurs territoires ont
subi des incendies avant ça mes chers
collègues l'année 2022 a été dramatique
avec des feux violents comme chacun s'en
souvient
je veux ici à nouveau saluer les
sapeurs-pompiers pour leur bravoure et
pour leur dévouement
je veux saluer nos agriculteurs et les
nombreux citoyens qui ont aidé lors des
feux dévastateurs de cet été
ce que nous a appris 2022 c'est que
désormais plus aucun territoire n'était
épargné par le réchauffement climatique
et que les incendies peuvent frapper
même au nord de la Loire
c'était improbable il y a quelques
années mais désormais c'est devenu une
réalité à Baugé en Anjou Avivi à
Beaulieu et même dans l'agglomération
Angeline l'été dernier vous le savez
monsieur le ministre près de 2000
hectares sont partis en fumée en
quelques jours nous devons nous adapter
à cette nouvelle donne nos moyens
doivent être suffisants face à cette
situation qui s'annonce récurrente
un certain nombre de mesures ont été
mises en place depuis octobre dernier
il reste encore beaucoup à faire très
concrètement monsieur le ministre la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
somme nous prêts pour l'été qui arrive
avec des territoires que la sécheresse
ne quitte plus
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique et
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Christophe Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Capu d'abord avant toute chose
je veux moi aussi puisque vous avez
commencé par là saluer les
sapeurs-pompiers de ce pays qui ont été
en première ligne l'année dernière et
dont nous savons à nouveau qu'ils auront
à faire preuve de leur courage et de
leur dévouement habituels pendant l'été
qui arrive
72000 hectares dont 60000 de forêts ce
sont les chiffres de l'année dernière
avec une particularité c'est le fait que
c'est feutres sont déplacés sur une
partie nord du territoire compte tenu du
dérèglement climatique vous avez cité le
Maine-et-Loire évidemment mais je pense
à la sarregue je pense au monde arrêt
depuis le 28 octobre date des annonces
du président de la République tout un
ensemble de choses ont été faites par
l'exécutif et je le dis par la Chambre
haute et par le Sénat au travers de sa
PPL
d'abord le rappel de la culture et de la
prévention des risques près de 3
millions de brochures pour rappeler les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
et à ce titre je salue la CMP qui
arrivera le 19 juin sur l'excellente
proposition de loi portée par le Sénat
qui clarifie et qui simplifie les Old
qui fait en sorte de prévoir une écho
redevance incitative pour financer des
campagnes de communication entre autres
je n'en ferai pas la publicité ici
puisque vous en êtes à l'origine nous
mettons ensuite en place une météo des
forêts qui s'est déployée dès le 2 juin
dernier deux enjeux donner une carte
rappelez les bons gestes et faire en
sorte que ce soit accessible sur
l'application Météo France
90% des feux dans notre pays mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sont d'origine
humaine et plus de la moitié sont liés à
des imprudences une étincelle un mégot
un barbecue
troisième volet au-delà de la prévention
au-delà de la météo
renforcer les moyens de lutte le fond
vert c'est 100 millions d'euros
qu'auront été fléchés pour l'achat de
caméra thermique et de drones par un
certain nombre de 10 et pour la
réalisation de corridor de sécurité
enfin les sapeurs-pompiers passages de
44 à 51 colonnes de renfort passage de
38 à 47 moyens aériens on peut jamais
dire qu'on est prêt mais tout ce qui a
été fait au cours de ces derniers mois
c'est pour protéger ceux qui nous
protège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
précisions et vos réponses vous le savez
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et ses conséquences sur nos
territoires c'est une préoccupation
principale de nos mères qui sont en
première ligne ils ont besoin de notre
soutien les annonces que vous faites
notamment sur la prévention sur leur
approchement des moyens aériens sur le
fond vert sur les sentiers notamment
sont une excellente nouvelle et vous
savez que le Sénat sera à vos côtés pour
améliorer encore les dispositifs
annoncés
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme
bachter pour le gros plaid républicains
monsieur le président
madame
tout va
vous avez conclu lundi le Conseil
national de la refondation sur le
logement je pense que vous êtes trompé
de discours et que vous avez conclu la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
fin de vie pour la pavillon individuel
fin de vie pour les investisseurs dans
l'immobilier fin de vie pour les
emprunteurs modestes
vous avez réussi l'exploit et l'oxymore
de faire un plan de relance
qui fait des économies
cela ne serait pas si grave si le
secteur de la construction n'était pas
aussi mal
en particulier vous avez oublié
toutes les mesures d'offres
rien sur les terrains rien pour
l'investissement et rien pour
solvabiliser alors madame la Première
ministre à quand le deuxième plan le
vrai plan de reconstruction pour le
terrain pour la France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement monsieur Klein
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jérôme bachel je voudrais
m'inscrire profondément en faux dans
tout ce que vous avez dit et je m'étonne
que vous soyez à ce point conservateur
d'abord le CNR a été un succès il a
permis de mobiliser plusieurs centaines
d'acteurs du logement de manière sans
précédentes ensuite ce CNR a été la
suite d'une mobilisation du gouvernement
et du gouvernement précédent sur le
logement je rappellerai le logement
d'abord ma prime rénove lanrue qui est
passé de 5 à 12 milliards pendant le
quinquennat précédent et surtout je veux
rappeler les propositions faites à
madame la Première ministre d'abord des
propositions pour sortir de la crise
47000 logements vont être rachetés ou
par la Caisse des Dépôts habitat ou par
Action Logement et c'est une force de
frappe sans précédent ensuite madame la
Première ministre a annoncé le maintien
du plan du prêt à taux zéro prêt à taux
zéro qui devait s'éteindre c'est cette
inscription se fait jusqu'en 2027 alors
que jusqu'à présent il était réinscrit
chaque année ensuite pour le Pinel
puisque vous parlez des investisseurs le
Pinel a démontré peut-être à un moment
sur l'utilité mais ces dernières années
plutôt ses inconvénients d'abord ces
inconvénients vous savez qu'on va à la
banque et qu'on vous propose à Paris
d'acheter un appartement à Tours et que
vous mettez jamais les pieds c'est
souvent des logements de piètre qualité
des copropriétés qui sont mal
entretenues parce que le propriétaire
bailleur nimait jamais les pieds ne
participent à aucune assemblée générale
de copropriété et oui nous faisons le
choix du logement intermédiaire porté
par des investisseurs
institutionnels parce que les
investisseurs additionnels vont gérer
bien mieux leur logement que pouvait le
faire aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'investisseurs ensuite madame la
Première ministre l'a dit elle a dit
très clairement vous n'avez peut-être
pas bien écouté son discours nous allons
mettre en place une lutte et lutte
contre la spéculation contre la
spéculation foncière à travers à travers
des nouvelles méthodes pour les services
des domaines pour que les services
fiscaux puissent plus évaluer le prix
des terrains je vous remercie
monsieur pas cher
monsieur le ministre vous appelez succès
ce que l'ensemble des professionnels du
sexecteur appelleraient un four non
monsieur le ministre vous trompez
l'ensemble des acteurs se sont plaints
des conclusions c'est pas parce qu'on a
beaucoup de monde que ça fait un bon
film non c'est un mauvais scénario que
vous annoncez pour la construction en
France il n'y a pas de mesure d'offre
vous l'avez restreigné je n'y peux rien
c'est comme cela et quand vous dites à
tort que la Caisse des Dépôts pas de
chance je suis membre du conseil de
surveillance de cette institution ne je
connais bien le plan elle fait pas un
effort comme jamais en 2016 déjà hélas
nous avions dû faire un effort bien
supérieur à celui là et on attendait
comme tous les Français comme tous les
acteurs comme tous les maires que vous
avez accusés de ne pas appliquer leur
plu vous avez accusé une fois de plus
les mers c'est une vieille habitude des
gouvernements macroniens et bien tous
ces acteurs attendent des vrais gestes
pour la construction et libérer la
construction vous avez parlé appartement
petit appartement c'est une mauvaise
vision du problème du logement
la parole est à notre collègue la
présidente Valérie d'état vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le Conseil
national de la refondation du logement
était celui de tous les espoirs vous
l'avez dit
bénéficiant d'une concertation inédite
d'un engagement total de la part de
l'ensemble des acteurs du logement et
fort de plusieurs centaines de
propositions le CNR devait constituer un
tournant ambitieux pour notre politique
du logement face à une crise sans
précédent pourtant ce CNR atout d'un
rendez-vous manqué les acteurs du
logement sont unanimes le compte n'y est
pas pire leur est à la désillusion et
votre déni ne change pas le résultat la
politique du logement ne semble
manifestement destinée qu'à être une
variable d'ajustement budgétaire si on
fait le bilan comptable de ce CNR c'est
plus de 2 milliards d'euros en moins
pour la politique du logement et ça ce
n'est pas acceptable c'est la
refondation du logement qu'on attend le
CNR n'était pas une fin soit déclaré
Olivier Klein
pouvez-vous nous assurer qu'il est tout
au moins le début de quelque chose nous
dire si dès le début du mois de juillet
des annonceront faites pour le logement
et qu'un plan d'ampleur sera enfin
annoncé pour répondre à la colère non
apaisée du logement
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Béchu
madame monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente état mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
le logement
[Musique]
a fait l'objet d'une d'un conseil
national de refondation et je salue le
fait que vous trouviez aujourd'hui à ce
CNR des mérites que vous n'aviez pas
nécessairement trouvé au moment où il a
été lancé et je vais donc préciser ce
qui a été le début de la conclusion de
la première ministre
ça a été d'expliquer et Olivier Klein a
fait juste avant elle que ce CNR c'était
pas la fin de l'histoire mais que
c'était un point d'étape qui permettait
à la fois de tenir compte de ce qu'avait
été une concertation et de regarder sur
ce qui arrivait devant la première
ministre a donné un rendez-vous à la fin
du mois de juin à l'ensemble des
ministres qui sont concernés à la Caisse
des dépôts et consignations pour aller
plus loin sur un certain de sujet et je
vais vous répondre au cours de ces
dernières semaines et ce sera
officialisé dans les prochains jours
nous avons établi une nouvelle
convention quinquennale avec Action
Logement voté à l'unanimité par les
partenaires sociaux vous saviez à quel
point c'était attendu vous
particulièrement madame la Présidente
l'état un certain nombre de mesures sur
le PTZ sur le BRS sur le taux d'usure
ont été précisés mais il nous reste un
énorme chantier c'est le pacte de
confiance avec les bailleurs sociaux
comment dans un contexte où il y a un
besoin de fonds propres il y a
l'augmentation du taux liée livret A
comment dans un contexte dans lequel on
a renchérissement du foncier comment
dans un contexte où il y a un enjeu de
rénovation énergétique de ce parc nous
pouvons poser les bases à la fois du
dispositif second de vie bloqué par la
première ministre et sur lequel Olivier
clin a déjà travaillé depuis des mois
avec l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
vous savez aussi que la remise à plat
d'une partie de la fiscalité sur la
location souhaitée par certains elle a
vocation a été examinée avant le début
du temps budgétaire annonce là aussi de
la première ministre je vous demande de
prendre ce point d'étape pour ceux qui
l'est une occasion de faire le bilan
dans un contexte où il y a une crise des
mises en chantier qui malheureusement
n'existent pas qu'en France parce que la
hausse des coûts d'un côté et le
relèvement des taux d'intérêt de l'autre
provoque à la fois cette crise de
l'offre et cette crise de la demande
pour répondre au sénateur bacheler c'est
donc une œuvre de longue haleine dans
laquelle nous sommes engagés il y a eu
un point d'étape il y a quelques jours
qui pose un certain nombre de choses
nous avons entendu ce qui s'est dit il
ne sait pas rien fait mais il reste à
faire
madame la Présidente
merci les propositions monsieur le
ministre issue du CNR laisse de trop
nombreuses questions en suspens et nous
avons besoin de réponses fortes en
dehors des métropoles point de salut
comment proposez-vous de répondre aux
besoins des territoires qui ne sont pas
en zone tendus comment accéder la
propriété en dehors des métropoles quel
parcours résidentiel pour les 2,4
millions de demandeurs de logement
social
14000 logements seront nécessaires sur
le soldatairequois pour faire tourner
l'industrie verte voulue par Monsieur le
Maire comment allez-vous faire péter Z
recentrer Pinel supprimé pouvez-vous
nous assurer que l'accession à la
propriété restera une opportunité
offerte au plus grand nombre et non un
privilège accordé à quelques-uns statut
du bailleur privé la mobilisation du
français ou et quand cuit de l'accession
sociale tous ces sujets attention parce
qu'avec ces propositions sinon on en
finit de l'accession populaire en
province monsieur le ministre on vous
fait confiance pour demain relever seul
défi faites-le faites-le vite c'est un
point de départ
c'est là que nous attend maintenant le
gouvernement doit être en accord avec
ses actes et ses engagements
la parole est à notre collègue Pascal
symbole Delhi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
avaient la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre chargé de la ville
et du logement
330 000 c'est le nombre de personnes
sans abri
4,1 millions celui de mal logé
2,4 millions celui des ménages en
attente d'un logement social en
Val-de-Marne vient d'être franchi le cap
des 100 000 demandeurs de logement dans
le même temps 5,7 millions de personnes
consacrent plus de 35% de leurs revenus
au logement deux mots me viennent
souffrance et irresponsabilité monsieur
le ministre beaucoup parlent d'une bombe
sociale réduction des aPL manque de
construction record d'expulsion et
maintenant suppression du dispositif
Pinel et pourtant si le logement coûte
38 milliards d'euros par an au budget de
la nation il en rapporte 88 milliards
alors comment expliquer vous que la part
du PIB consacrée au logement n'est
jamais été aussi faible 1,5% 2021 un
record jamais atteint
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Pascal ça vole merci pour votre
question qui me permet de compléter je
sais votre attachement au logement en
général et au logement social en
particulier et à l'hébergement d'urgence
je voudrais vous redire ce qui a été
fait dans le précédent quinquennat sur
le l'hébergement d'urgence d'abord le
plan logement d'abord c'est 440 000
personnes qui ont aussi de la rue au
logement madame la Première ministre l'a
annoncé lors de la fin du CNR le plan
logement d'abord 2 va être lancé il a
déjà commencé cette année vous savez que
les acteurs de la solidarité sont au
cœur beaucoup de municipalités font
partie des territoires d'accélération du
plan logement d'abord et c'est 160
millions d'euros supplémentaires pendant
le quinquennat nous allons mettre sur le
deuxième plat dont je vois d'abord vous
le savez aussi l'hébergement d'urgence
fait partie des priorités de ce
gouvernement je rappelle quand même 120
000 places d'hébergement d'urgence en
2017 plus de 200 000 encore ce soir plus
de 6 millions chaque soir sont dépensés
ensuite oui il faut continuer à
accompagner le logement social vous le
savez c'est pas un bâton de maréchal
mais je suis fier d'être un fils du
logement social et d'y avoir habité
longtemps au début de ma carrière
d'enseignant et il faut soutenir le
logement social ce que nous avons fait
en plafonnant l'augmentation du taux du
livret A il faut soutenir le logement
social dans sa capacité à rénover là
encore nous avons fait une annonce
importante sur la seconde vie dans du
local de rénovation lourde qui permettra
au bailleur d'accéder à l'exonération de
taxes foncières sur le foncier bâti et
puis nous allons travailler comme la
rappeler le ministre Christophe vichu un
pacte de confiance extrêmement ambitieux
avec l'Union Sociale de l'habitat et je
peux vous assurer que nous ne sommes pas
des festifs au contraire nous allons au
signer ce pacte de confiance dans les
mois qui viennent en tout cas à
l'horizon du Congrès HLM qui se tiendra
à Nantes merci
monsieur cheval de vie
je vais m'adresser à madame la Première
ministre vous êtes autorisé à réemployer
les initiales du CNR et face à une crise
du logement sans précédent permettez-moi
madame la Première ministre de ce que je
pense que nous pensons que devrait
porter le Conseil National de la
Résistance aujourd'hui le gel immédiat
des loyers avec une compensation pour
les bailleurs sociaux la généralisation
de la TVA à 5,5% pour la construction de
tous les logements sociaux la
généralisation des aides à l'accession
sociale à la propriété mais également
interdire toutes les expulsions sans
solution de relogement de revaloriser
immédiatement les APL tenant compte de
l'inflation et de l'indice de référence
des loyers de plafonner les prix de
vente des logements en zone tendues de
taxer davantage les plus-values
immobilières pour financer le Front
national des aides au logement et incité
à baisser les prix de vente de durcir
les sanctions envers les communes qui le
respectent pas les obligations la loi
sérieux madame la Première ministre la
seule opposition la seule opposition la
conquête du droit universel au
changement je m'excuse de vous le dire
mais c'est vous et votre gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
est ok pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Papin DIY
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre la grève des
personnels de l'enseignement primaire
dur depuis 5 semaines voir 6 à Wallis
dans l'indifférence presque totale
les grévistes sont déterminés à
continuer le mouvement parce que l'État
les traite différemment
54 ans qu'ils assurent une mission de
service public sans reconnaissance de
l'État et pourtant en 2006 une
ordonnance du 15 février étant dit à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et la Polynésie
française l'application de la loi du 5
janvier 2005
relative à la situation des maîtres des
établissements d'enseignement privé sous
contrat pardon
du dispositif au motifs qu'il n'y avait
pas lieu de le faire car l'enseignement
du premier degré y est concédé sans que
pour autant les mettre relèvent de
l'article
l.914-1 du code de l'éducation
au regard de ces disposition la
convention de concession avec la dette
n'était pas un frein pour l'habilitation
et conformément aux modalités de
recrutement de recrutement fixés par
l'État nos maîtres sont titulaires d'une
licence des métiers de l'enseignement
ils sont agréés par l'État et signe un
contrat de travail avec le vice rectorat
qu'il est gère et les paye directement
monsieur le ministre nous en
conviendrait la demande des grévistes
que leur soit reconnu le statut d'agent
public de l'État dès la rentrée 2024
avec tous les avantages liés et
parfaitement légitime les enseignants à
Wallis exploits sont des citoyens
français nos enfants sont des enfants de
la République et doivent retourner en
classe enfin comptez-vous rétablir cette
situation particulièrement injuste et
inéquitable créé aux dépens des
personnels enseignants du premier degré
en étendant la loi dite sensi à
wallis-phe
je vous remercie
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur culinotoke vous
m'interpellez au sujet des maîtres de et
maîtresse de Wallis et Futuna en grève
effectivement de puis le 2 mai pour des
raisons salariales je rappelle qu'à
Wallis et futunal les enseignants du
premier degré sont des agents de droit
privé puisque l'enseignement est concédé
à l'enseignement catholique et que donc
c'est professeurs sont employés par des
la Direction de l'Enseignement
Catholique néanmoins c'est l'État qui
assure des rémunérations à hauteur de
4500 euros brille brut mensuel sans
compter les primes en outre ces
enseignants sont recrutés à bac + 2
contrairement à la situation ordinaire
recrutement à bac + 5 je sais Monsieur
le Sénateur que vous vous êtes entretenu
avec mon cabinet ainsi qu'avec celui du
ministre des Outre-mer j'ai donné mandat
à la vis rectrice de Wallis et Futuna
pour que les négociations avec force
Ouvrière éducation aboutissent au plus
vite nous avons proposé des
augmentations de rémunération j'ai
également donné mon accord pour que des
groupes de travail se mettent en place
afin de comparer la situation des
maîtres et maîtresses de
Wallis-et-Futuna avec leurs collègues de
nouvelles Calédonie et que effectivement
on étudie la possibilité de leur
permettre d'accéder au statut d'agent
public de l'État vous le voyez monsieur
le sénateur nous suivons de près la
situation des quelques 150 mètres et
maîtresses concernées auquel vous faites
allusion cette situation est suivie
notre objectif c'est que les élèves
retrouv ent au plus vite les bancs de
leurs écoles
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Viviane artiguelas pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le logement va mal c'est un
secteur en crise tous les indicateurs
sont à la baisse vente de logement mise
en chantier nouveau permis de construire
dans le même temps on compte plus de 2
millions de personnes en attente dans
logement social un record après plus de
6 mois de travail d'échange et de
concertation les attentes étaient fortes
mais lundi soir avait la conclusion du
CNR logement la montagne a accouché
d'une souris la colère du secteur est à
la mesure de sa déception face à un plan
jugé minimaliste et imprécis qui n'a
conservé que très peu de ses
propositions les deux copilotes du CNR
logement les acteurs de l'immobilier de
la construction et de la solidarité tous
ce centre méprisés par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre il faut une
impulsion forte pour répondre à la crise
du logement pourquoi n'avez-vous
toujours pas pris la mesure de ses
conséquences économ omiques et sociales
[Applaudissements]
de la ville et du logement
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Viviane Artigalas comme ça a
été rappelé plusieurs fois ce CNR et
vous l'avez vous même rappelé a été un
moment extrêmement important de
mobilisation et de travail des acteurs
du logement et ce CNR et tous sauf un
point final c'est un moyen de travailler
de méthode de nouvelles méthodes de
travail sur laquelle nous allons nous
appuyer pour la suite néanmoins notre
priorité et c'est probablement celle de
nous tous ici c'est de construire un
parcours résidentiel aux Français quel
que soit l'état de leur compte en banque
et pour ça il faut avoir des mesures
équilibrées des mesures équilibrées en
termes d'accession à la propriété
d'accession abordables à la propriété
c'est le sens du maintien du PTZ c'est
le sens du bail réel solidaire sur
lequel nous souhaitons mettre l'accent
car le bail réel solidaire est une vraie
bonne méthode pour permettre l'accession
à la propriété pour les classes moyennes
et nous allons le booster dans les mois
qui viennent c'est le sens des
discussions que nous menons avec Bruno
Le Maire et l'ensemble des banques pour
l'accès parce que aujourd'hui une des
difficultés c'est les taux d'intérêt et
l'accès au crédit et ça rend encore plus
utile le PTZ dans cette période
particulière ensuite c'est l'accès à la
location pour ceux qui en ont besoin le
logement locatif intermédiaire c'est un
des meilleurs moyens que nous avons pour
faire le lien entre l'emploi et le
logement et c'est pour ça que nous
allons le développer dans des zones plus
grandes et nous allons y travailler le
logement locatif intermédiaire est le
même produit final que le Pinel que
certains semblent regretter enfin nous
avons décidé de multiplier par deux
l'accès à visal là aussi dans le cadre
des accords que nous menons avec Action
Logement et là encore visale c'est une
mesure de protection du pouvoir d'achat
c'est la caution à ceux qui n'ont pas de
caution passer de 1 million à 2 millions
de visa c'est extrêmement important et
extrêmement utile pour nos concitoyens
ma priorité notre priorité c'est de
d'aider les Français dans leur parcours
résidentiel et je terminerai comme tout
à l'heure par le logement social le
travail sur le pacte de confiance que
nous avons déjà commencé est un travail
extrêmement important tant pour la
rénovation que sur la production neuve
le travail que nous menons aussi sur la
hausse du livret A et la manière dont
nous compensons cette hausse du livret A
avec la Caisse des dépôts et l'ensemble
des acteurs du logement merci
madame Martigues beaucoup d'intention
mais peu de fait l'effet sont têtus
monsieur le ministre la politique du
noble logements n'est pas la priorité de
votre gouvernement quelle réponse
faites-vous au milieu de famille qui
peinent à se loger dignement aucune
incommensation des aides au logement
encore moins du forfait APL et pour
cause toutes ces aides ont été
dépouillées durant le premier
quinquennat quelle réponse pour les 2,4
millions de citoyens demandeurs de
logements sociaux pas de baisse de la
RLS ni de la TVA pour le logement social
alors que l'on manque de logement
abordable quelle réponse sur le foncier
rien pour redonner un peu d'autonomie
fiscale aux élus rien que pour permettre
aux jeunes d'accéder la propriété dans
les territoires qui les ont vu même
naître aucune mesure non plus pour
lancer la dynamique de la construction
perdue depuis 2017 où est la refondation
promise le ministre des comptes publics
a déjà annoncé que le secteur du
logement subir une nouvelle baisse dans
le budget 2024 la crise du logement va
s'aggraver et ce sera la cause à cause
de votre inaction
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole à notre collègue
Garrigole pour le gros du Rassemblement
démocratique sociale européen j'en
profite pour lui souhaiter un bon
anniversaire voilà
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le ministre la banalisation de
la violence dans les écoles dans les
stades dans l'espace public envers nos
élus envers les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique ou assurant une
mission de service au public est un
constat tristement partagé dans cette
période émaillée de nombreuses crises
l'augmentation des tensions et le
recours à la violence sont des signaux
d'alerte à considérer avec une immense
gravité
une partie de la population y compris la
jeunesse fait aujourd'hui le choix des
extrêmes et de l'abstention qui battent
élections après élection des records
toujours plus inquiétants les signes
d'un malaise démocratiques qui s'accroît
comme d'autres je me rends régulièrement
à la rencontre des plus jeunes dans les
écoles dans les collèges dans les lycées
de mon département
j'y mesure combien malgré le travail des
enseignants le sens de l'engagement de
la République et des valeurs citoyennes
peuvent sembler éloigner de leur réalité
mais j'y mesure également la
méconnaissance de nos institutions et de
notre fonctionnement démocratique
tout ce qui va de pair avec une moindre
compréhension de la décision politique
et de ce fait une moindre acceptation
des lois et des institutions ce défaut
se défis démocratique nous devons le
relever
au-delà des dispositifs déjà mises en
place qui relèvent davantage des mesures
curatives que de mesure préventives le
groupe RDSE a initié avec notre collègue
Henri Cabanel un travail collectif pour
développer le sens de lagagement et la
culture citoyenne
des propositions pour permettre à chacun
de trouver son rôle et sa place dans une
société apaisée pour s'inscrire dans un
projet commun avec des références
partagées des propositions ou
l'éducation fait figure de priorité car
l'ignorance est le terreau de la
défiance car l'école est le lieu où se
forment les futurs citoyens monsieur le
ministre quelle mesure concrète
envisagez-vous pour mettre en place une
véritable culture citoyenne à l'école je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole du
communiste de l'éducation nationale la
jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur et rigole très bon anniversaire
à vous votre question
pose en effet
plus largement une question fondamentale
qui est celle de l'engagement citoyen de
notre jeunesse et donc au fond celle de
l'avenir de notre République et de notre
démocratie l'enseignement moral et
civique auquel vous faites allusion fait
partie des enseignements obligatoires
dispensés du CP jusqu'à la terminale et
le rapport de votre collègue Henri
Cabanel fournit un certain nombre de
points d'appui et de proposition tout à
fait pertinente j'en retire d'une part
que cet enseignement d'éducation morale
et civique doit être réellement effectif
à tous les niveaux ce qui n'est pas tout
à fait le cas aujourd'hui c'est souvent
une variable d'ajustement deuxièmement
c'est le contenu de cette enseignement
moral et civique sur lequel il faut se
pencher la connaissance de nos
institutions les valeurs de la
République la capacité à chacun de nos
élèves d'avoir un engagement éclairé les
programmes d'enseignement moral et
civique vont donc être revus et nous
allons nous assurer de leur mise en
oeuvre dans toutes les classes par
ailleurs nous devons aussi nous assurer
du bon niveau de formation des
professeurs et vous savez qu'une épreuve
spécifique portant sur l'appropriation
des valeurs de la République dont la
laïcité a été proposée et mise en oeuvre
pour les concours du CAPES et de
l'agrégation à partir donc de la session
2022 lors des oraux d'admission de ces
concours je pense aussi et enfin à la
nécessité de l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information nous savons le rôle
délétère des réseaux sociaux dans un
certain nombre de cas il est donc très
urgent de développer l'esprit critique
de nos élèves vous pouvez tant sur
l'éducation morale et civique que sur
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information compter sur moi monsieur
le sénateur
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
broyer pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre l'ISF climatique
pour nous c'est oui écoutons les
scientifiques le dernier rapport du GIEC
nous dit et nous répète que l'urgence
climatique est là plus violente et plus
rapide que prévu écoutons Jean Pisani
Ferri et Selma fouze qui confirme
l'absolu nécessité de réorienter les
financements publics vers tout ce qui
rend notre société plus durable et
résiliente écoutons les experts et les
élus dont les écologistes qui vous
interpellent pour que les collectivités
soient soutenues plus de 25 milliards
par an doivent être mobilisés à leur
niveau pour amortir les chocs annoncés
du plus 4 degrés en France Monsieur le
Ministre nous n'avons plus le choix il
faut faire en disant ce qui n'a pas été
fait en 30 c'est un changement d'échelle
et d'enjeux tous les leviers doivent
être activés sans attendre et
s'enfléchir et les plus riches doivent
être mis à contribution d'abord parce
qu'ils sont les plus pollueurs mais
aussi parce que les 378 ménages les plus
sont ceux qui payent le moins en
proportion de leurs revenus comme le
souligne la note de l'Institut des
politiques publiques publiées hier et
aussi tout simplement parce que la
transition écologique doit se faire dans
la justice sociale monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire comment vous allez
financer la transition et l'adaptation
de notre pays au bouleversement
climatique puisque vous dites non à un
impôt vert exceptionnel sur le
patrimoine financier des 10% les plus
riches vous disent également non un
endettement pourtant légitime pour faire
face à la gravité exceptionnelle de
cette crise climatique monsieur le
ministre Aqua dites-vous oui
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Briard d'abord je voudrais
souhaiter un bon anniversaire à Sophie
prima puisqu'il n'y a pas de raison
si on souhaite l'anniversaire des
rigoles qu'on ne souhaite pas se vide la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques et je le dis
je le dis à dessin
parce que le rapport Pisani ferry qui
fait un peu moins de 160 pages il
commence par expliquer que économie et
écologiste ça va pas forcément l'un
contre l'autre et que la décroissance
n'est pas le chemin et qu'on peut
concevoir une trajectoire écologique qui
s'accompagne une trajectoire de
croissance je le dis le rapport Pisani
ferries dit autre chose il dit que ce
sont pas des mesurettes ou des symboles
qui sont à la hauteur de la marche et il
explique et il valide la planification
écologique portée par la première
ministre la méthode de ce gouvernement
méthode à laquelle je dis oui comme je
dis oui elle est nécessité qu'on fasse
en sorte précisément de pouvoir faire en
sorte secteur par secteur de
proportionner les efforts alors
vous choisissez un angle qui correspond
à deux pages sur les 160
et je souhaite
et je souhaite vous répondre en vous
disant la chose suivante
il y a pas de tabou sur la fiscalité
sauf que le débat sur les symboles il
finit par nuire à l'essentiel si
l'écologie devient le prétexte si
l'écologie devient le prétexte pour
interdire et pour taxer on va renforcer
l'impopularité de ces mesures auprès
d'une partie de la population et on
s'éloignera des objectifs l'enjeu
monsieur le sénateur broyeur vous le
savez c'est pas la transition d'un impôt
c'est la transition fiscale quelle
transition fiscale on fait quand on
passe de l'essence à l'électrique alors
qu'il y a 40 milliards d'euros qui sont
appuyés sur la TICPE comment est-ce
qu'on assure une trajectoire de
transition fiscale qui fait qu'on
renchérit l'artificialisation pour faire
en sorte de rendre possible un zan
assoupli en tenant compte des besoins
des territoires ruraux mais dans le même
temps en donnant aux mer les moyens de
lutter contre la dépollution des friches
comment on baisse la fiscalité sur le
foncier non bâti pour les agriculteurs
si ça doit s'accompagner de la baisse
d'une partie roulement c'est assez
réflexion globale et collective que je
vous donne rendez-vous dans les semaines
qui viennent pour parler de cette
transition monsieur broyer quelques
secondes
chez le ministre merci de me répondre
par des questions pour la crise covid
vous avez mobilisé sans compter et
c'était heureux pour la crise climatique
c'est non et ça nous choque monsieur le
ministre si la dette financière est un
sujet sérieux et la transition fiscale
une nécessité commencée par l'ISF
climatique qui est une demande partagée
largement sur tous les bancs de cette
émission en tous les cas sur un grand
nombre de ses bancs et sur
tous les bancs de la gauche et par
beaucoup de nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle 170 élus vous ont
demandé pour conclure de créer cette ISF
c'est désormais une pétition il vous
appartient de la rendre caduque
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue Alain Milan
pour le groupe les républicain oui merci
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Madame Firmin de vaudot je
souhaite madame la ministre à tirer
votre attention sur les inégalités de
traitement entre les professionnels de
santé revendent la fonction publique
hospitalière et ce exercice dans des
établissements privés ou privés à but
non lucratif en effet en juillet 2022
vous avez décidé une majoration
exceptionnelle de certaines indemnités
horaires notamment du travail de nuit et
des heures supplémentaires majoration
reconduite jusqu'au 31 août 2023 c'est
majorations sont accordées aux
professionnels des hôpitaux publics il a
été ainsi accordé 531 millions d'euros
en 2023 et 760 millions d'euros cumulés
en 2022 au
929.000 personnes du secteur public
hospitalier hors personnel médical ces
majorations ne concernent que la
fonction publique hospitalière à
l'exclusion des professionnels des
établissements privés et associatifs qui
sont eux 284 000 et qui remplissent les
mêmes missions et répondent des mêmes
modalités de financement et de
régulation de leur activité la situation
de notre système de santé appelle à la
mobilisation de tous pour répondre aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens la
crise sanitaire a montré que des
synergies étaient possibles entre les
établissements de santé de différents
statuts cet esprit covid doit être
préservé il passe donc par la
reconnaissance de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé de tout statut
soumis à de fortes tensions dans un
contexte de pénurie en ressources
humaines madame la ministre dans un
contexte où nous avons besoin la
mobilisation de tous comment expliquer
ce traitement inéquable et comment
comptez-vous être la garante de l'égal
reconnaissance de l'engagement de toutes
et de tous
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé madame Firmin le
Bodo merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Milon vous le savez
le ministère de la Santé accorde une
attention forte à protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des professionnels des hôpitaux
dans les différents secteurs aussi à
côté des revalorisations salariales
prévues par l'accord du Ségur pour la
fonction publique hospitalière nous
avons pris des mesures en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat des personnels des
établissements privés une revolisation
socle correspondant à 183 euros net par
agent pour le privé non lucratif
c'est-à-dire un montant équivalent à
celui du public et 160 euros nets
mensuel pour l'agent dans le privé
lucratif la reviliarisation des
carrières et rémunération appliquée au
métier du soin que la fonction publique
est sur l'ensemble de la carrière
compensée par un montant global pour le
secteur privé d'environ 220 millions
d'euros les revalorisations des
carrières et des rémunérations des
sages-femmes ainsi que la prime
d'exercices en soins critiques pour les
infirmiers et cadres de santé ont
également été mises en place dans le
privé avec des financements associés par
ailleurs vous l'avez signalé en ce qui
concerne les majorations des nuits et
des gardes les mesures mises en place
suite à la mise sur les urgences et
soins non programmés sont des mesures
exceptionnelles et transitoires
conformément aux orientations du
président de la République sous
l'autorité de la première ministre
François brome et moi-même travaillons
pour avancer vers des systèmes de
valorisation plus pérenne pour
reconnaître l'engagement spécifique lié
à ce travail de nuit nous mono également
un travail en profondeur sur la
permanence des soins il nous faut en
effet mieux associer comme vous l'avez
souligné tous les acteurs publics et
privés pour prendre en charge tous nos
concitoyens même pendant la permanence
des soins la synergie est possible elle
a été pendant les cris sanitaire nous
essayons de la pérenniser ce sujet est
d'ailleurs débuté dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi visant à améliorer
l'accès aux soins par l'engagement
territorial des professionnels dont
l'examen a débuté à l'Assemblée
nationale cette semaine
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais quand même rappeler ce que
vous aviez dit à l'époque parce qu'il
avait dit le ministre à l'époque à
reconnaître les suggestions
particulières attachées au travail de
nuit et à faire aux difficultés aux
tensions anticipées sur l'offre de soins
dans les prochaines semaines et
prochains mois c'est à mesure que vous
avez prise cette mesure concerne
uniquement pour l'instant dans le cas
des majorations les personnels non
médicaux hospitaliers des hôpitaux
publics et pas des hôpitaux privés ce
que nous souhaitons c'est que tous les
personnels qui travaillent de la même
façon soient reconnus merci
[Musique]
notre collègue très bien pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
de Chanel de Dina pour qu'on s'attaque
réellement au harcèlement scolaire
aujourd'hui l'émotion est forte et la
vague d'indignation nous submerge tous
et demain la question du harcèlement
risque de retomber dans l'oubli pendant
que des jeunes continueront de souffrir
monsieur le ministre je vous ai
rencontré en février dernier avec ma
collègue Colette Melo et vous sembliez
très mobilisé et soucieux d'avancer vite
et fort sur le sujet de mettre en place
certaines mesures de notre rapport
sénatorial et de veiller à l'application
du programme phare sur tout le
territoire or ce que je constate sur le
terrain ce sont des disparités d'un
établissement à l'autre là où le climat
est apaisé ou l'effet de harcèlement
sont contenus et traités c'est lorsque
l'équipe éducative et les services
académiques se sont saisis des
dispositifs là où ça se passe mal c'est
quand cette question n'est pas une
priorité là où les moyens manquent où là
où l'on préfère le pas de vagues il faut
savoir aussi que le programme PHARE
n'est pas toujours appliqué ou pire
n'est pas connu dans de nombreux
établissements que les associations sur
le sujet se voit refuser l'accès à
certains collèges au motif que tout va
bien tout ceci est inadmissible et ne
peut plus durer monsieur le ministre
avez-vous enfin l'intention de rendre
obligatoire l'application des
dispositifs existants vous déciderez
vous à augmenter les moyens de contrôle
de la mise en œuvre effective des
mesures par un renforcement des
recrutements de personnels éducatifs et
médico-sociaux qui manquent cruellement
entendez-vous renforcer la formation des
enseignants et personnels à la
prévention la détection et au traitement
du harcèlement comment améliorer la
coordination entre les services de
l'éducation nationale de la police de la
justice afin que la parole de l'enfant
soit prise en compte pour qu'il soit et
se sentent protégés et comment
comptez-vous contraindre les réseaux
sociaux à la modération effective du
flux d'information en circulation et à
la publication de messages d'alerte à
destination du jeune public je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse monsieur
merci monsieur le Président et mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Vaneck nous avons avancé ces
dernières années en matière de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire mais il
nous reste encore beaucoup à faire et
effectivement nous avons du pain sur la
planche nous avons d'abord fait du
harcèlement scolaire un délit grâce à la
loi Balanant de mars 2022 les numéros
308 et 30 20 ont été créés et leur
audience s'élargit la formation des
personnels a été engagée et comme vous
l'avez rappelé le programme phare a été
généralisé avec des disparités j'en
conviens à toutes les écoles et tous les
collèges depuis la rentrée 2022 nous
nous inspirons en partie du rapport de
l'excellent rapport que vous avez rédigé
avec la sénatrice Colette Milo pour
aller plus loin
d'abord voilà les mesures concrètes que
j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer d'abord la nomination d'un
adulte référent
un adulte référent harcèlement dans tous
les collèges
infirmiers CPE professeur pour assurer
le suivi personnalisé et en temps réel
des situations de harcèlement
l'extension du programme phare au lycée
et d'une manière générale le fait de
s'assurer que ce programme est
effectivement mis en place dans tous les
établissements la saisine systématique
du procureur de la République en cas de
suspicion avérée de harcèlement ou de
situation préoccupantes la création
d'une équipe départementale
d'intervention dédiée au harcèlement
pour régler les situations les plus
complexes le déplacement de l'élève
arceleur suivant en cela d'ailleurs une
proposition de la sénatrice Mercier dans
le premier degré le décret a été
transmis hier au Conseil d'État et puis
enfin la formation massive des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
l'augmentation significative des moyens
alloués aux plateformes d'écoute 30 18
et 30 20 madame la sénatrice je suis au
premier rang avec le gouvernement et la
première ministre pour faire reculer ce
fléau intolérable que le harcèlement
scolaire
vous avez quelques secondes monsieur
chers collègues
en fait le semis il y a rien de nouveau
sous le soleil tout ce que vous annoncez
existe déjà et n'est pas appliqué ce que
je vous demande c'est de passer des
paroles aux actes
la parole est à notre collègue Véronique
delfabro pour le groupe les républicains
cette question s'adressait à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Justice dans la nuit du
15 juin Édouard Babel maire de manière
village paisible de 400 habitants dans
le Lunévillois a été violemment agressé
par 10 individus après avoir tenté de
mettre fin à un tapage nocturne malgré
cette agression profondément attachée à
ce mandat local le maire très choqué ne
démissionne pas je veux lui montrer ici
tout mon respect et lui apporter mon
plein soutien mais cette énigme violence
ne doit pas nous faire oublier
l'incendie criminel du domicile du maire
de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins ni le décès en
2019 du maire de cygnes certes depuis
2017 l'état agit pour assurer la
protection des élus en multipliant les
dispositifs renforcement du dispositif
de protection fonctionnelle par la loi
engagement et proximité instruction de
fermeté donnée au parquet pour renforcer
la réponse pénale mobilisation accrue
des forces de police et de gendarmerie
nationale sur le terrain aux côtés des
élus malgré cela la violence des élus
est en hausse de 32% en 2022 mais pas
que la violence au niveau des élus la
violence en général le constat est sans
appel monsieur le ministre votre action
ne suffit plus face à la déshumanité des
humanisation de la société qui agresse
nous policiers nous pompiers tu nous
soignants nous enseignants et nos élus
monsieur le ministre quand agirez-vous
pour faire appliquer concrètement des
sanctions disciplinaires exemplaires ou
pénale pardon pour ce que c'est sans fin
cette violence devenue un phénomène de
société
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales et la
ruralité madame Dominique Faure
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice delfabro
avant tout je tiens au nom de la
première ministre au nom du ministre de
l'intérieur et au nom de tout le
gouvernement a renouveler notre soutien
et notre solidarité à Monsieur Édouard
Babel je tiens aussi à saluer son
courage sa détermination avoir porté
plainte et je veux le citer il le fait
pour défendre l'intérêt général de tous
les élus qui est aussi à saluer la
mobilisation du corps préfectoral de la
gendarmerie du procureur qui ont été en
soutien actifs et aux côtés de Monsieur
Babel dans cette douloureuse épreuve
alors c'est ensemble
par une très bonne coordination
que l'ensemble des services et je les
recite préférée gendarmes et procureur
ont permis au parquet de Nancy dès le
lendemain de l'agression d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire pour violence
aggravée outrage et menaces de mort sur
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique l'enquête est en cours et
plusieurs individus sont déjà
interpellés
alors les solutions vous en avez cité
beaucoup qui sont déjà en oeuvre
plusieurs circulaires à la fois du
ministère de l'Intérieur et de Gérald
Darmanin à la fois du garde des sceaux
ces dernières années
c'est très tôt
évaluer la menace évaluée la gravité des
faits protégé instantanément et puis
vous l'avez dit sanctionner alors c'est
tout le sens de ce que nous faisons que
nous accélérons ces 3400 référents dans
la gendarmerie et dans la police des
référents violences faites aux élus qui
vont à la rencontre des élus ils étaient
identifiés que par certains élus ils ont
aujourd'hui consignes clairs d'aller à
la rencontre des élus d'être
identifié je veux aussi en profiter pour
rappeler parce qu'il y a énormément de
cyber violence c'est surtout la
cyberviolence qui a augmenté ces
derniers mois une plateforme Pharos dans
j'ai déjà le cas monsieur la semaine
dernière monsieur le sénateur donc cette
cyber violence il y a une plateforme
auprès de laquelle tous nos concitoyens
peuvent signaler les frais et leur
gravité et elles peuvent être des
référencés donc c'est dans une logique
de transport c'est dans une logique
transpartisane que nous travaillons
actuellement veille fréquente et
proactive de nos gendarmes répond
systématique rapide et opérationnel et
réponse judiciaire ferme et systématique
maintenant vous terminez s'il vous plaît
j'ai terminé
je transmettrai à Monsieur Babel votre
message il est vrai qu'il a été très
entouré vous avez dit plusieurs
individus avait été interpellé c'est une
bonne chose mais quand on regarde à
Villerupt sur le dernier épisode qui
s'est passé dans une Meurthe-et-Moselle
qui est pourtant un département très
calme l'individu qui a été auteur des
faits a été interpellé 34 fois alors
permettez-moi un petit peu d'être étonné
et un petit peu de dubitative juste une
chose il y a vraiment une crise
d'autorité dans notre société ou
certains et même de plus en plus
s'affranchise de toutes les règles
allons-nous attendre que le pays soit
affreux instant pour avoir une réponse
pénale implacable avec le sourire voilà
la parole est de notre collègue
Jean-Pierre Moga pour le groupe de
l'Union centric
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé de la ville et du
logement et j'y associe mon collègue
Pierre-Antoine Lévy depuis quelques
semaines descends abris l'Île-de-France
sont transférés vers les villes de
province bien que le gouvernement s'en
défende le lien avec les Jeux Olympiques
et peut-être la Coupe du monde de rugby
s'impose la pratique a déjà été observée
à Rio en 2014 à Shanghai en 2010 lors de
l'Exposition Universelle avait des
dérives que l'on sait
ces déplacements chocs et il pose la
question de l'accueil et de la
compagnement des personnes déplacées
dans des régions où les sons envoyés la
pratique interroge aussi sur les liens
entre l'État et les collectivités en
effet les sangles que les mers
découvrent ces déplacements sans en
avoir été informés Adamo et sans que
leur avis ait été sollicité monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
sur les modalités de ces déplacements
comment la répartition territoriale des
sans-abri franciliens étaient le
réalisée les élus locaux sont-ils
consultés ou placés devant le fait
accompli
quel accompagnement social est prévu
pour les personnes déplacées monsieur le
ministre ne pensez-vous pas que les mers
ont besoin d'un peu plus de transparence
et de considération je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes délégués en charge de la
ville et du Logement merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jean-Pierre mauga merci pour votre
question qui va me permettre de rétablir
quelques quelques vérités le travail
d'accompagnement en province des
personnes sans abri de la région
parisienne est un travail qui semaine
avec les associations de solidarité
depuis plusieurs mois c'est une
réflexion qui est en cours qui a l'appui
des associations de solidarité car vous
le savez sur les 200 000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence que nous ouvrons
chaque soir plus de la moitié sont dans
Paris et oui nous ne savons pas bien
accompagner ces grands nombres en région
parisienne et il est important de
trouver de meilleures solutions en
partenariat avec le préfet de région
j'ai eu le maire de Bruz et je vous
donnerai son numéro de téléphone si vous
le voulez pour vérifier qu'il avait bien
été informé en amont oui il avait été
informé plus de trois semaines avant de
ce dispositif il faisait partie de la
concertation et bien évidemment nous
demandons au préfet d'associer les élus
locaux à cette démarche et nous continu
à le faire mais oui nous pensons que un
accompagnement en petite nombre dans nos
régions parce que c'est la solidarité
nationale c'est l'honneur de la France
d'accueillir les personnes en
hébergement d'urgence parce que
l'hébergement est inconditionnel mais
nous devons le faire dans de meilleures
conditions que nous le faisons
aujourd'hui parce que l'hébergement
d'urgence dans les nuitées d'hôtels
éparpillées en tâche de léopard en
Île-de-France ne permet pas cet
accompagnement social et administratif
je tiens à vous dire aussi que cette
accompagnement est fait sur la base des
volontariats avec les associations les
personnes qui sont accompagnées en
province sont informés on leur propose
d'aller en province et ensuite au vu de
leur évaluation ils pourront revenir en
Île-de-France seront raccompagnés sur
leur situation administrative dans leur
pays est insoluble et sinon resteront en
province dans des lieux de tension sur
l'emploi je vous remercie
monsieur Moga
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le ministre je prends
acte de votre réponse mais vous
comprendrez qu'après l'épisode de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins il serait
regrettable de créer une nouvelle
tension avec les mers qui souvent
l'impression d'être tenu pour quantité
négligeable sans verser dans le malgame
la comparaison s'impose aussi avec la
situation des migrants là encore une
répartition territoriale et parfois
faite sans que les élus leur mot à dire
ce genre de décision je pense que vous
le comprenez doit être prise en
concertation avec les collectivités
locales pour assurer leur succès
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue malgré son pour le groupe les
républicain
mais si monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre agriculture le 29 avril pour
faisiez passer le risque grippe aviaire
d'élever à modérer le 3 mai elle
refaisait son apparition dans les Landes
le grs les Hautes-Pyrénées et les perles
les attentes la Calmy a été de courte
durée dans le Sud-Ouest et la sidération
depuis 7 ans chaque vague a été plus
violente tous les modèles ont été
touchés patrimo celui des élevages en
plein air toutes les riposte dépassées y
compris la frustration tous les
territoires frappés l'ensemble de la
filière touchée ce lundi vous annoncez
entendre la désespérance tout en
confirmant une campagne de vaccination
pour octobre prochain enfin semble se
briser le tabou autour de la vaccination
à bière mais octobre est une date
lointaine infiniment lointaine car la
vigueur viticole est particulièrement la
filière gras du Sud-Ouest est à genoux
beaucoup d'éleveurs ont baissé les bras
beaucoup se sont endettés pour appliquer
les mesures de biosécurité beaucoup
attendent encore les indemnités des
abattages antérieurs monsieur le
ministre la vaccination n'est pas la
panacée mais c'est une réponse dont on a
que trop longtemps attendu la mise en
œuvre c'est la raison pour laquelle les
quatre chambres d'agriculture réclament
pour cet été le déploiement du vaccin
aussi en associant à cette première
question mon collègue Patrick chaise
appliquerez-vous la vaccination aux
élevages de labellisés AOP comme ceux du
pays de presse pouvez-vous préciser
quelle sera la part à la charge des
éleveurs eux qui attendent toujours le
versement des indemnisations des
abattages antérieurs enfin et surtout
peut-on dans le Sud-Ouest accélérer le
processus de vaccination
je ministre
de l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Brisson merci de
votre question qui me permet de faire un
point effectivement d'abord dire ce qui
s'est passé au 14 mars dernier nous
avions imaginé que nous étions sortis de
l'épisode de l'année 22 23 puisque nous
n'avions plus de cas avéré et ça avait
justifié d'ailleurs des mesures de
relâche sur un certain nombre de mesures
sanitaire malheureusement et ça avait
particulièrement bien fonctionné je
tiendrater dans votre région en
nouvelle-aquitaine puisque grâce au plan
Adour de désensification dans les zones
les plus impactées on avait très peu de
cas puisqu'on avait eu simplement 28
foyers contre 360 années 1 l'année
passée on peut dire que ces mesures
elles fonctionné malheureusement vous
l'avez dit on a assisté au début du mois
de mai à une résurgence du virus dans le
Gers d'abord puis en
Pyrénées-Atlantiques puis dans les
Landes et donc on a de nouveau de la
désespérance qui s'est créé d'abord dire
qu'on a pris des mesures classiques
d'abattage dans les les élevages
infectés de détensification dans
d'autres cas et des abattages sanitaires
à l'extérieur de ces de ces de ces Périm
voilà deuxième élément sur lequel on a
travaillé c'est de regarder sur lequel
on continue à travailler c'est
d'accélérer vous avez raison il y a de
la désespérance y compris économique
d'aller accélérer les indemnisations qui
étaient dues et deuxième élément de
faire en sorte qu'on ait des
indemnisations plus rapidement perçues
sur les nouveaux cas qui viennent
d'apparaître dans cette région et puis
vous-même interrogez troisième point sur
la question de la vaccination nous avons
dit que nous serions en capacité à faire
des expérimentations à partir du mois de
juin de l'an dernier puisqu'on a besoin
d'autorisation européenne on a été au
rendez-vous nous avons dit que nous
expérimenterions jusqu'au mois de mars
on a été au rendez-vous du calendrier
j'ai dit qu'à l'automne ou vaccinerions
en particulier les palmipèdes parce que
c'est ceux qui sont les plus touchés
nous serons au rendez-vous j'entends
l'inspiration parce que c'est impatience
c'est les nourries de la désespérance
d'éleveur qui sont au deuxième ou
troisième épisode mais nous sommes sur
un sujet vaccinal nous avions besoin de
qualifier de le vaccin c'est fait depuis
quelques jours nous avons fait des
précommandes pour accélérer le processus
et donc on sera bien au rendez-vous de
l'automne si on peut un peu accélérer on
le froid mais il faut qu'on le fasse en
bonheur pour que s'assurer que d'un
point de vue sanitaire ça se passe dans
de bonnes conditions
si vous avez quelques secondes
[Applaudissements]
je comprends les problèmes techniques
qui s'opposent à une accessoire rapide
alors dans ce cas il faut un plat un
plan d'urgence sinon quand le vaccin
arrivera les éleveurs ne sont plus là
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Patrick jolie pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 24
mai dernier à l'occasion de l'examen
annuel de la situation économique et
sociale de la France et de ses
perspectives la Commission européenne a
constaté je cite que la France est
caractérisée par des disparités
régionales croissantes qui vont au-delà
du clivage persistant entre région
métropolitaine et ultra périphérique
elle ajoute également selon ces termes
que la fracture entre zones urbaines et
zones rurales en termes de dynamisme
économique et de perspective de
croissance et devenue une préoccupation
politique et qu'il est important de
remédier au déséquilibre régionaux pour
notamment améliorer les perspectives de
croissance à long terme de la France
elle préconise enfin au conseil de
demander à la France pour reprendre sa
formulation de procéder à la mise en
oeuvre rapide de programmes de politique
de cohésion en lien avec le plan de
relance et de résilience en vue
d'accélérer une transition écologique
sociale économique num érique équitable
et inclusive alors Monsieur le Ministre
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur ce
diagnostic impitoyable et savoir comment
le gouvernement envisage de répondre aux
recommandations de la Commission
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguée en charge du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs Patrice Joly effectivement le
paquet printemps de la Commission
européenne formule un certain nombre de
recommandations comme cette son habitude
de le faire d'ailleurs vous en citer
quelques-unes je vois que vous prenez
soin de ne pas noter d'autres
recommandations qui feraient peut-être
moins de succès sur vos banques comme la
nécessité de réduire la dépense publique
par exemple monsieur le sénateur nous
allons dans le sens de ce que veut la
commission surtout lorsque vous parlez
d'harmonisation du territoire entre
réalité et territoires urbain en matière
industrielle c'est tout le sens de la
politique qui est conduit depuis
plusieurs années et qui est amplifiée
d'ailleurs j'en veux pour preuve les
premiers résultats alors que nous avons
pendant plusieurs décennies enregistré
une réduction du nombre d'entreprises
dans notre pays d'industrie qui fabrique
qui produisent pour la première fois
depuis trois ans nous réintroduisons des
entreprises et le et le bilan entrée
sortie entre les fermetures et les
ouvertures d'usine et positif de l'ordre
de 300 entreprises ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle et quand vous regardez
d'ailleurs vous ne vous y trompez pas le
président de la République est all é où
il est allé dans le la région des Hauts
de France puisque c'est notamment ici
qu'il y avait un déficit encore plus
important qu'ailleurs d'entreprises qui
fabriquent et qui produisent et donc il
a souhaité qu'on mette le paquet dans
ses territoires parce que c'est une
richesse pour notre pays
ensuite vous interrogez sur les
réflexions de la Commission européenne
s'agissant du verdissement de notre
économie c'est justement là aussi le
sens de ce qu'a présenté la première
ministre le président de la République
l'ensemble du gouvernement sur le projet
de loi industrie verte et qui va dans le
sens d'une industrie des carbonée qui va
dans le sens de nous permettre demain en
français et en Europe 1 de fabriquer à
nouveau sur notre territoire les
instruments indispensables pour
participer à la rénovation thermique ce
sera quand même mieux quand on fait de
la rénovation de l'habitat des Français
de pouvoir leur proposer des pompes à
chaleur fabriqué en France ou des
panneaux solaires fabriqués en France
vous voyez on inscrit nos pas en
l'occurrence dans ceux de la Commission
on peut avoir des désaccords sur
d'autres aspects mais ce sur lesquels
vous m'interrogez je crois que l'épreuve
sont tangibles monsieur le sénateur
monsieur Joly
sur le président monsieur le ministre il
est urgent d'agir s'en y est
effectivement un certain nombre
d'avancer tel que vous avez pu les
évoquer en matière de territoire
d'industrie les chiffres témoignent de
cette urgence le PIB par habitant en
Île-de-France et de 57100 euros contre
29200 en moyenne pour les autres régions
la part de la population exposée au
risque de pauvreté ou d'exclusion
sociale s'élève à 22,4% dans les
honorales contre 19,2 dans les
agglomérations l'espérance de vie en
zone rurale est inférieure à deux ans à
celle constater en ville
urgence donc à mettre en œuvre une vraie
politique d'aménagement du territoire
global avec des moyens l'auteur des
enjeux de la cohésion sociale qui se
délitent ce qui remet en cause notre
République par ailleurs il y a trois ans
le rassemblée à l'unanimité avait
demandé au gouvernement à l'occasion de
la présidence française de l'Union
européenne d'agir fortement pour la mise
en place d'une vraie politique
européenne destinée au territoire ruraux
au-delà de la PAC et à la hauteur de ce
qu'il pèse sur le plan démographique
cela reste aujourd'hui un impératif sur
lequel il y a lieu d'agir de manière
déterminée je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Cédric
Perrin pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres des armées même si il est
retenu à l'Assemblée dans quelques mois
se tiendront les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 c'est une chance mais c'est
aussi une charge d'un point de vue
sécurité nous le savons et nous le
constatons tous les jours en Ukraine les
drones peuvent représenter autant un
atout qu'une menace très élevée en 2021
la Direction générale de l'armement a
notifié au consortium Thalès CS groupe
le marché dénommé parade pour doter la
France la dispositif de lutte antidrone
or il semble aujourd'hui que la solution
n'est absolument pas opérationnelle je
ne doute pas de vos efforts pour
atteindre le résultat qui soit
satisfaisant mais aujourd'hui avec quel
matériel je n'ose imaginer alors que
nous étions une référence au sein de
l'OTAN que nous soyons aujourd'hui prit
de vitesse je n'ose imaginais que nous
soyons contraints de faire appel à des
importations pour la protection des Jeux
Olympiques
je nous enfin imaginer que nos ambitions
de souveraineté soient rabaissées au
moment où la loi de programmation
militaire projette le contraire monsieur
le ministre l'enjeu est crucial elle a
représentation nationale mais aussi les
Français et les visiteurs du monde
entier ont besoin d'être rassurés notre
dispositif de lutte antidrone est-il oui
ou non opérationnel sera-t-il testé
comme le gouvernement l'a promis au
salon du Bourget la semaine prochaine et
pour la Coupe du monde de rugby en
septembre prochain et enfin est-il bien
made in france merci beaucoup
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État en charge du service
national universel madame Sarah et Lary
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Perrin je
vous prie d'excuser je vous recherche du
regard monsieur le sénateur c'est bon je
vous ai retrouvé monsieur le sénateur je
vous prie d'excuser effectivement le
ministre des armées qui est retenu dans
le cadre du vote de votre solennelle de
la lepremas militaire à l'Assemblée
nationale mais monsieur le sénateur vous
avez raison aujourd'hui la lutte anti
drone est un sujet absolument essentiel
d'autant plus essentiel qu'il impacte
nos opérations extérieures et notre
sécurité intérieure encore plus dans le
cadre d'échéances particulièrement
importante à sécuriser comme les Jeux
olympiques ou paralympiques monsieur le
sénateur la loi de promo aggramation
militaire elle a évidemment intégré un
budget de défense solaire
particulièrement ambitieux plus de 5
milliards d'euros 350 millions d'euros
particulièrement pour la lutte antidrone
ils seront consacrés mais aussi des
moyens supplémentaires en termes
législatif l'article 27 en particulier
qui nous permettra de renforcer le
régime légal permettant d'élargir entre
autres la possibilité de brouillage
monsieur le sénateur ou la
neutralisation de drone au titre de la
Défense nationale en s'appuyant sur des
nouvelles technologies de nouvelles
menaces bien sûr on y fera face le
ministre des Armées développe dès à
présent des innovations indispensables
comme des armes à énergie dirigées ou
encore des drones qui intercepteront
évidemment d'autres drones menaçant en
tout cas pour augmenter la sécurité
monsieur le sénateur sur le système
parade que vous avez évoqué la
contractualisation a eu lieu en 2021 il
a été effectivement contractualisé avec
Thalès et CS groupe aujourd'hui 6
exemplaires ont été commandés en 2022
neuf supplémentaires sont prévus dans la
LPM le système est en cours de
vérification monsieur le sénateur depuis
fin avril évidemment comme tout système
d'armes complexe il fait l'objet de
quelques difficultés mais en cours de
résolution pour équiper évidemment et
accompagner nos industriels monsieur le
sénateur le ministère des armées sera en
mesure d'assurer la protection des JO
contre les menaces grandissantes et nous
ne ferons pas appel à des solutions sur
étagères et donc ce sera des industriels
français je vous remercie
je suis très heureux que vous nous
soulignez que ce seront des industriels
français qui procéderont à la protection
d'une autre ciel et de nos spectateurs
lacrologie la chronologie était pourtant
très simple il s'agissait évidemment
d'abord d'acquérir un système qui soit
opérationnel ensuite de le monter en
compétences au Bourget à la coupe du
monde de rugby et ensuite enfin de
pouvoir le l'utiliser de manière
efficiente au Jeux Olympiques
aujourd'hui le système de fonctionne pas
il n'existe pas et moi j'essaie de
savoir comment vous allez faire pour
utiliser ce système à la coupe du monde
de rugby ce que je vous demande
aujourd'hui est-ce que je demande au
ministre des Armées c'est de faire en
sorte que le ministère des armées et la
Délégation générale à l'armement ce
coordonne pour faire en sorte que la
capacité française qui existe
aujourd'hui dans nos forces puissent
être réunies pour que chacun que les
industriels travaillent ensemble pour
que la France soit enfin à la hauteur en
matière de lutte anti-drone pour la
Coupe du monde de rugby et pour les Jeux
Olympiques ensuite merci
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
quesnoir pour le gros plaie républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre après les déclarations
successives d'un certain nombre de vos
collègues la première ministre a
confirmé ce lundi que le gouvernement
envisage bel et bien l'interdiction de
du remplacement de chaudière à gaz dans
l'ensemble du parc immobilier et cela
dès 2026 à l'issue d'une concertation
avec les acteurs de la filière
l'objectif de décarbonisation de notre
mix énergétique et maintenant largement
partagée même si la France ne contribue
qu'à hauteur de 1% des émissions de de
CO2 dans le monde et il faut bien sûr
trouver des solutions rapides et
concrètes pour aller dans ce sens mais
certainement pas comme le dira le
président de la République pour emmerder
les Français
or cette mesure pénaliserait très
lourdement les 12 millions de foyers
français qui se chauffent actuellement
au gaz puisque les solutions
alternatives comme les pompes à chaleur
coûte environ trois fois plus cher
qu'une chaudière à gaz performante cette
mesure déstabiliserait également toute
une filière qui est en pleine mutation
et qui attend des marques de confiance
pour continuer à promouvoir la
production de biogaz sur notre sol en
réalité notre pays a besoin de davantage
de constance dans la parole de l'État et
surtout d'en finir avec une politique
écologique punitive qui multiplie les
interdictions madame la ministre
pouvez-vous préciser les attentes et les
intentions du Gouvernement dans cette
concertation avez-vous la volonté
d'entendre les arguments de bon sens qui
dans la concertation qui débute
pour vous répondre la parole dans la
ministre de la transition énergétique
madame panier renacé
évidemment il y a le secteur du bâtiment
le secteur du logement et notre objectif
c'est d'avoir des logements moins
énergivores moins émetteurs de carbone
c'est une nécessité pour notre planète
mais c'est aussi plus de confort et
moins de factures pour les Français moi
émetteur de carbone cela veut dire de
logement consommant moins de gaz et
moins de fuel pour être chauffé ou
refroidir ce travail vous le savez il
n'a rien de nouveau je rappelle qu'il
n'est plus possible par exemple
d'installer des chaudières gaz et des
chaudières fuel dans les constructions
neuves et que nous avons arrêté les
installations les soutiens à
l'installation de ce type de chaudière
mais nous devons aller plus loin c'est
pourquoi nous avons avec mes collègues
Christophe Béchet Olivier Kain
l'enseigne concertation publique mardi
sur la décarbonation du secteur du
bâtiment et notamment sur l'accélération
la décarbonation des moyens de chauffage
cette concertation elle va nous
permettre de travailler sur des
solutions concrètes et accessibles
accessibles en prix vous avez mentionné
le point il est tout à fait valide tout
en anticipant la montée en puissance
dans nos usines d'alternatives et de
fabrication de de nouvelles types de
chaudière à carbone c'était également
mentionné par mon collègue Olivier Véran
à l'instant il ne s'agit donc pas de
prendre des décisions drastiques et
immédiates gouverner c'est prévoir
prévoir c'est anticiper c'est ce que
nous faisons au bénéfice des Français et
de nos entreprises monsieur piennois
il y a qu'un jour votre collègue le
ministre Christophe Béchu disait ici
même qu'on en avait fini avec l'écologie
punitive
s'il vous plaît donc je vous demande
simplement n'ouvrez pas la voix une
nouvelle colère sociale ne faites pas
payer aux Français les Allemands et les
volts de l'exécutif si ces dernières
années nous savons tous de quoi nous
parlons ne laissez pas les foyers les
plus modestes supportés une mesure qui
est totalement déconnectée de leur
réalité au quotidien je vous remercie
bien merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
en avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le mercredi 14 juin à 15h je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
d'approvision de loi maintenant
provisoirement au dispositif de
plafonnement de revalorisation de la
variation annuelle des indices locatifs
on ne quitte pas le logement la séance
est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au